hey guys in this video i'm going to give
you my best tips to be more attractive
now please understand this is not about
being vain
this is just about having enough respect
for yourself to take good care of
yourself and to look good and let's be
honest you want to look good you want to
look professional the best that you can
for work or for your girlfriend for your
wife
and of course they will appreciate it if
you don't take good care of yourself in
grooming
styling taking care of your health and
so forth then people will make
assumptions about you
we know you shouldn't judge a book by
its cover but people do it all the time
they look at someone they make
assumptions based on the way that they
dress their hair everything and so when
they look at you and you don't just make
the effort they all think man you're
probably one of those guys that don't
really respect yourself you don't care
about anything you might look more
unprofessional at work less approachable
lazy uneducated
sloppy and dirty
no that's not what you want to look like
to others you got to take care of
yourself in the way you carry yourself
the way you present yourself to others
take care of your body because it is a
temple so in this video i'm gonna give
you my best 25 tips to be more
attractive not just look attractive to
be more attractive let's get to it
um
[Music]
get a good skincare routine some guys
they don't care about skincare routines
so some people who
who are 30 they look like they're 60.
some guys they've got problems with
blackheads others they get problems with
pimples we all have different skin
issues
look your face represents who you are
and over time your face will take on and
start to show all the harsh conditions
it went through over the years so just
start to use a very good skincare
routine that will help your face to look
clean fresh and healthy i personally use
geology which is a personalized skincare
routine and i'll also add some other
good options for you in the video
description below
[Music]
be more self-aware and empathetic
towards others
a lot of guys these days are very
selfish arrogant and you can see they
don't really care about other people
it's so unattractive this self-absorbed
attitude is the most unattractive thing
in the world
if that's you at least you know why
people try to avoid you like the plague
it doesn't matter how much money you
have how good you look how good you
dress if you have a
bad attitude you will always look ugly
to other people you have to be unselfish
think about the feelings and interest of
other people a lot more that will make
you a decent human being and more
attractive to other people
choose the right haircut for your face
shape this is more important than you
think let me give you some examples an
oval face shape might look good with
most hairstyles because it is
proportioned well
while on the other hand a square face
shape might work better with an undercut
or a quiff now a heart shape looks good
with a quiff as well and maybe a
textured fringe and if you have a round
face stay away from round shapes curly
hair instead try longer hair on top and
shorter hair on the sides and then if
you have an oblong face shape try a
sleek back style or a side part or even
a man bun if you feel adventurous
if you wear too much hair on top man
your face gonna look super super long
like a pompadour it's definitely not
gonna work
now if you're happy with your haircut
you need to learn to use the right
products there's a huge difference
between gel pomade wax hairspray and
play and hey if you're not sure which
products to use which you can trust
again i'll add my best options for in
the video description below now for a
sleek bag for example you can use gel
but if you want a nice crew cut that's
short on the sides with a side part
it'll be better just to use pomade or
wax and maybe a little bit of hairspray
depending on your hair thickness
[Music]
grow a nice beard i didn't even know
that i could grow this beard
you just have to try to see what kind of
beard you can grow
a lot of guys feel that their face well
it doesn't look so attractive and when
they look in the mirror the symmetry is
not all there if that's you what you can
do is grow a cool beard style that will
fit in with your face shape some men
look a lot better with a cool beard it's
like they
they were born just to have a beard all
you gotta do is just grow it out and try
a few different styles
i made a video about different beard
styles that you can check out after this
video
don't go overboard when styling your
clothes look from all the years of
modeling that i've been doing
i've realized that a lot of designers
brands they just bring out new trends
new things because well they want to
make money number one number two they
get bored of the current trend so they
just develop new ones never go for
trends
because everyone
will do it and then you won't stand out
and trends of course
it will always pass so me personally i
stick to basic good quality clothes that
will never go out of style
that saves you a lot of money and you
look good
when it comes to putting on different
outfits
you gotta
try not to look like someone that's
trying too hard
in all honesty the people who dress the
best
they look like they just happened to put
these clothing styles on and they look
cool in it because they don't look like
they've been obsessing over it and
remember
it's not just about what you wear
it's how you wear it
[Music]
improve your posture you gotta develop a
new habit of walking setting
standing everything you do do it with a
good straight posture why
because then you'll automatically look
more confident and attractive cindy ann
peterson said good posture is important
for health reasons as well as for your
appearance because it reflects your
personal attitude this is so true just
think about it whenever you walk
somewhere for example the mall when you
walk past people everyone walks
different the way they carry themselves
you know this one he walks a little bit
more of a with a funky interesting
attitude the other one walks very
straight the other one is like slouching
it tells people about your attitude who
you are now a good tip if you strengthen
the muscles in your back it will
definitely help you with good posture so
don't skip those back days in the gym
[Music]
take care of your shoes and clean them
you know i don't understand guys
are so lazy
that they don't clean their shoes i mean
if you walk around in dirty shoes all
the time people will think you are dirty
apart from making you look better
cleaning and polishing your shoes every
now and then will make the shoes last
longer and save you more money as well
[Applause]
never ever have bad breath
nothing puts people off as much as bad
breath when you come close to someone
you talk to them and you just smell
and the worst thing people with bad
breath they usually don't even realize
it because they're used to their own
smell that bad breath
dying smell
a lot of guys out there brush their
teeth two to three times a day which is
great but they forget about their
tongues
you know when you have that funky
feeling uh here in your mouth it's
usually a sign of bad breath there's
this
eewy stuff on your tongue give you stuff
i don't even know where that comes from
anyway this discolorant kind of white
stuff
scrape it off clean it off and if you're
away from home
and you can't go and brush your teeth at
least carry some mints with you i always
keep some mints in my car i use
fisherman's friend because i like their
name because i like fishing and mints
work plus you can get them sugar-free
always just dress a little bit better
than the situation requires never
overdress because then you'll feel weird
and never underdress because then you'll
be the odd one out and always remember
whatever you wear wear it with humble
confidence because nothing looks better
than that
[Music]
always wear matching socks if it comes
to socks and you're not sure what color
to wear
it's easy just stick to the basics and
just wear the same color as your pants
and please
throw those socks away with those holes
in them
you know what i'm talking about and that
goes for underwear as well
[Music]
eat healthy this should be common sense
by now guys you got to take care of your
body your body will thank you you'll
feel better not only that you will look
better as well and if you don't know how
to eat healthy then i'll add some good
videos for you in the video description
that you can check out you know you only
have one life don't waste it by eating
unhealthy food a lot of people these
days
get health issues
but it's their own fault just because
they do not eat healthy
working out just like eating healthy
this is common sense guys to look good
to look more attractive you gotta work
out you have to get in shape to look
healthy and more attractive not only
will your body look better but your face
will also look more attractive and
you'll get back your jawline
now if you don't like working out just
try two days a week and just do certain
exercises that you like some guys don't
like running on the treadmill but they
like riding a bicycle or start a new
sport that you like just get moving not
only will you start to look good you'll
feel good but you'll have more energy as
well and
when you wear clothes
it'll look better on you as well
[Applause]
have a basic pair of shoes for every
occasion good looking quality shoes but
you don't need a whole closet full of
shoes all you need is great quality good
looking shoes that fit every occasion i
made a video about it that you can also
watch after this video and i'll list my
favorite shoes for you in the video
description if you want to check it out
[Music]
stop using gel a lot of guys use gel
they just spike it
well you can use gel if you want a nice
sleek back look or you want to
want to go to a formal event and you
want to have that wet look but for other
occasions if you want to have healthy
looking hair just use pomade or wax
because then your hair will look more
natural and if you're struggling to
style it all you got to do is use
something like sea salt spray before use
the blow dryer and then style it into
the position you like then just use a
little bit of the pomade or the wax and
then a little hairspray for the final
touches
[Music]
show someone that you are listening to
them and i mean physically show them
show them look them in the eyes don't
look at your phone don't look away
your body language also give a lot away
when you're not interested in someone
and then when you do that they feel
disrespected think about it for a moment
when you talk to someone and you realize
man you're trying to talk to this person
and they just
they don't care they're not really
listening they're not focusing on
anything you're saying you feel
disrespected right
well that's exactly how they feel when
you do it to them and also never
interrupt someone when they're talking
you know when i was young my dad would
give me a hiding almost
you would discipline me if i did it
i grew up with
my dad teaching me how to be a gentleman
today
most guys don't even care it's so
disrespectful
respect other people give them the
opportunity to have their say and when
they're done then
you can go and talk
[Music]
when you go shopping always bring
an honest friend or even your girlfriend
or wife with you when you go shopping
for clothes
why
because
you should never ask a salesperson hey
how does this look does it look good is
it too tight is it how does it look
because they will always tell you it
looks great sir man you need to buy this
because they need to earn some money as
well they need to make a living right so
they will tell you anything you need to
hear so that you will buy their product
[Music]
groom your ears and your nose
look
you might be young you say i don't have
any hair well the older you get the more
hair you will get
in places you don't want them to grow
and you know when i travel i always see
a lot of guys walking around with these
hairs growing just
peeking out of their nose you can't even
focus when you're in a conversation with
them because you just stare at those
hair nah guys get rid of it groom
another tip i feel like i almost don't
have to say but
let's do it here it goes
improve your clothing style
it is true that the well in most cases
the clothes do make the man especially
when it comes to first impressions
avoid clothes that are too tight for you
and avoid clothes that are too big for
you as well and then you gotta wear the
right clothes on the right occasions
casual smart formal outdoor and so forth
be ready for every occasion
[Music]
always be friendly always be kind and
always be positive why
because no one likes someone with a bad
attitude that's number one number two
there's something in psychology that's
known as the halo effect what is it well
it's basically a bias where you
unconsciously take one aspect of
somebody as a proxy for their overall
character so what does this mean
well it's when people
make an assumption about who someone is
their total personality their attitude
who they are as a human being by looking
at only one aspect and there's been a
lot of research studies on this research
shows that people who are more kind
friendly positive they're rated as being
more attractive than other people
[Music]
be yourself in all situations never lie
about who you are and never pretend to
be someone else let me explain it this
way
being an original
is worth more than being a copy of
someone else
listen carefully you can always improve
yourself alright we always strive to be
better than we are we currently are than
who we were yesterday
but never
pretend or try to be someone else
because i've said this in this in
previous videos but i'll say it again
you were never meant to be someone else
you're meant to be the only you in this
world
[Music]
always use deodorant or antiperspirant
there's nothing worse than a guy
smelling like sweat all the time it's
terrible and most of the time they don't
even realize it because they get used to
the smell now i always use nivea
invisible black and white antiperspirant
it works great and it doesn't leave any
stains on my clothes but antiperspirant
is not enough to smell good you need a
good clone that suits you and when you
find it use it every day
why because pretty soon people will
identify the smell with you
smile more
guys the world is already a hard place
a lot of people walking around with sad
faces
faces
and a lot of people just suck the life
out of you because they're so negative
but if you smile more
you're positive you look happy you're
like sunshine you will draw people to
yourself now i don't mean a weird smile
here like
creepy no just an honest genuine
smile a lot of young guys today
they don't want to smile they don't want
to
wear that smile on their face because
they think man they'll just look like a
good guy they want to be a bad cool guy
but what you're not realizing is if
you're trying to look cool all the time
you just look angry you just look
negative
it looks cool in movies you know when
they have this cool attitude and the
slow motion well in real life you can't
walk in slow motion
wear a smile because it's the best thing
that you can wear on your face
[Music]
learn some manners
if your parents didn't teach you good
manners to be a gentleman
then you got to learn it's one of the
best things that you can learn in this
world
it separates the boy from the man
margaret walker said friends and good
manners will carry you where money won't
go and emily post said
good manners reflect something from the
inside an innate sense of consideration
for others and respect for self
it's true isn't it
it's extremely off-putting when i see
young guys or even older guys
with no manners at all you know when
you're on public transport and you see a
young guy sitting there on a chair and
he's not giving space he's not standing
up asking an old lady to come and sit
down
or a guy who does not show his
girlfriend or wife the respect she
deserves their actions flow from their
heart
so just imagine how black that heart is
full of selfishness
be confident in who you are
self-confidence
have confidence in your identity
believe in yourself
self-confidence is very attractive very
other people will believe in you
why
because if you don't have confidence in
yourself if you don't believe in
yourself you can't expect other people
to do it and here's something
interesting that you need to learn
confident self-confidence does not come
from your achievements it comes from
knowing your identity
who you are and
who god made you to be
[Music]
all right the bonus tip now this is
super important because a lot of people
in the world
it seems like they're forgetting this
and it is so
important
because being attractive is not just
about having a good face about having an
attractive handsome face it's about
having an attractive mind it's about
having an attractive heart an attractive
soul
and please if you're still young
always remember this having a kind and
caring heart in a cruel world is not a
weakness at all it's a strength and it
takes courage because you won't let the
cruel world influence you and if you
won't let this cruel world affect you
then you
are a warrior
and always remember this life is short
so don't waste yours
i'll see you in the next video cheers
guys